vectors in Python
essentially a list or you can even use
two poles to do this
Create three vectors and python.
over
and I'm going to use linear algebra terminology.
are
Yeah.
to the power
and where
it is equal to 5.
Okay.
And call or declare.
these
vectors
with
you know, we sub 1 V sub 2 V sub 3
so in Python, we use something called snake notation.
As opposed to camera case stack notation is when you
deliver it.
characters or variable or even functions with underscore instead
of
Cowboy casing them
Put the vectors.
V sub one is up to we sub three.
oops
inside the Matrix
Math, yeah.
M.
and this would be
so we have
each Vector has five.
A components and we have three vectors. So that's three.
times five
and you want to declare this Matrix?
the clear
this Matrix
with
See, here's the problem in Python. We use uppercase letters
for classes.
not
yeah, we don't use uppercase that is because it met for classes, but
and well, let's take the lower class big lower
clusters because we cannot violate Python Programming conventions.
and then for number three
convert
the
Matrix
to a numpy
array, how do you do this using the code?
NP dot array
the method
so there's a difference you what you cannot you cannot perform.
Matrix operations on python lists not
unless you you write a function to implement them,
but you can do this with the numpy array. So if you
have two numpy arrays, you can add them as if they were two vectors and that's
what the library is built for.
and then finally
add the
elements
of the row space
of
M.
Remember the word space.
means set
so we're talking about the set of elements.
So if
It's a space of a matrix then the
elements of a matrix could only the row space
of a matrix can only be three vectors.
So I might suggestion is
to see if we can do the first two. I just want to see if everybody's clear
on the terminology so far and then you can attempt to
do three to four.
Okay, let me add a note here.
For number three, you need to import.
Numpy and you can do this.
With this code so it would go import.
NP and numpy as MP
Okay.